vamos a empezar nuevo luego
vamos a hablar del tiempo
se le dedica ahora mucho tiempo a la
salud
que no comas esto que no comas esto otro
que es la carne que yo soy vegetariano y
luego el otro dice no no es cierto
los confundo nomás por todas las
tonterías cuando 90% de la anualidad
nomás con mis frijoles entonces para qué
preocuparnos tanto digo pero como le
dedicamos tiempo a eso y los
restaurantes y toda otra cosa que le
digamos donde tiempo es a la salud no
como hace esto los aminoácidos este los
gimnasios están llenos está ahí haciendo
pesas y todo el sereno y qué bien me veo
que cree que son negros siguen siendo
los mismos
pero hay una cosa que no le dedicamos
tiempo es el tiempo
no hay cursos sobre el tiempo no hay
opiniones sobre el tiempo
eso no se discute
y el tiempo
es muy importante porque el tiempo nomás
se mide
y una cosa muy importante es que todos
tenemos nuestro tiempo limitado
o nos van a vivir 30 años
en otros 40
yo voy a cumplir 80 y los que tienen 100
pero nos llega un momento en que nos
vamos
entonces de esa situación es la que
tenemos nosotros que ver cómo la vamos a
administrar el tiempo
y se nos ocurre
nuestro
y personal como comunidad como país está
muy muy muy ligado a cómo distribuimos
nuestro tiempo
como lo empleamos
por ejemplo
cuando empezó al cetis aquí una de las
cosas que a pantalla mucho del cetis es
lo que se dijo la hora cetis
porque porque estaba en esos tiempos él
ingenio hacia rendón y empezó una junta
de consejo y dejó noquear a las 9 ya las
9 y los consejeros no llegaron al médico
de piel dijo ah y desde entonces esta es
ahora cetis y ya se hizo aquí en el set
es una tradición de que hay que ser
puntual es una tradición yo me pasé seis
años en el senado que aquí dijeron yo yo
no soy político yo soy arquitecto
constructor ese es mi fuerte he estado
metido en cosas de política pero ese es
un complemento que yo lo hago por ser
ciudadano pero en el senado que fueron
más difíciles de mi vida yo les aseguro
que perdí el 30% de mi tiempo esperando
se citaba el grupo parlamentario a las
10 de la mañana y el tiempo era yo
yo soy el único que llega para planear
cómo estaba la j
y era un desastre había un peinador allí
todas las mujeres iban y se peinaban eso
para los que spain en su casa así que no
le hagan perder el tiempo a otros y
dijeron que me iban a vencer que me iban
a ser impuntual no no me hicieron
impuntuales
en los seis años lo que tienes que
llegar a tiempo pero yo llega con cosas
para trabajar pero no me vencieron
porque yo el tiempo de otros uno lo debe
respetar
eso es un principio de educación
respetar el tiempo de otro los países
civilizados saben lo que es el tiempo
ustedes hacen esos ajustes por ejemplo
con un japonés
de las empresas que hemos trabajado un
americano de otros de esos países de
primera y dice el debemos en nueva york
en el hotel fulano
el 27 de julio a las ocho y media de la
mañana y ahí están ahí están a las ocho
y media de la mañana
o sea que la gente le da importancia al
tiempo propio y de los demás
aquí nosotros por ejemplo como podemos
tener un buen sistema escolar de
primarias y secundarias donde hay paros
de maestros 70.000 fiestas se nubla el
cielo y no van a la escuela no se vayan
a mojar luego estamos grabando
y una raza de gente que no está
preparada para el futuro con cualquier
cosa se tropieza
huelgas que le dan mal ejemplo que no
hay buen clima pues no vas a la escuela
eso no sucede en otros lados la escuela
se va 9 otro año desamparo así es
eso es lo que hace a un país diferente
de otros hace 12 días se juntó nuestro
presidente con el de salvador llegó 90
minutos tarde
margen tan acostumbrados eso no hay
grandes actividades en esos países no
hay una situación de retos
mañana los citan uno a uno a una boda
aquí y le dicen vete a las siete ya
saben todos que van a empezar la boda de
las ocho entonces bajé los citan a las
siete
si te valora que va a ser la boda porque
el tiempo
no vuelve el tiempo se va y se va y se
va los padres buenos de familia tienen a
sus hijos ocupados
para que aprovechen su tiempo es un
curso de verano que esto que esto otro
un deporte esto esto siempre están
ocupados
poco tiempo le dan contra el peligro más
grande que hay en lo manejado ahora que
se estoy
este es un embrutecedor
es un arma de dos filos es muy buena y
muy mala
entonces quiere que ellos tengan rutinas
buenas de ejercicio todo porque también
así se hace disciplina el que empieza a
aprender a usar su tiempo se hace
disciplinado
tiene que hacer esto una hora tiene que
hacer esto otro ahora y siempre está
ocupado y entonces esa persona empieza a
desarrollar sus neuronas más aquí parece
que no hay muchos alumnos de prepa y de
profesional la mayoría son de posgrado
me dicen pero un lugar donde hay que
aprender a usar el tiempo es en la
escuela no hay cosa más triste en una
escuela que un tipo que poncha tarjeta
para darles pactaría a las clases no hay
cosa más triste porque porque en la
escuela no se va eso nada más de
aprender muchas cosas por ejemplo
no sé pero quienes participaron en un
equipo que represente al cts a vázquez
fútbol teatro ga minorías
cuando el tecnológico de monterrey el
tecnológico monterrey o aprendido dormir
siesta
les digo todo
no había dormido una siesta hasta que
llegue al tecnológico de monterrey
porque es lo que estaba en el equipo de
fútbol americano en el equipo de
natación boxeaba afuera en la coliseo no
sacaba malas notas le tenía pavor a mi
papá
e historia y dos más fiesta cualquiera
puede descollar en una escuela mexicana
cualquiera de veras se los digo entonces
hay que aprovechar el tiempo que saber
hacer ejercicio a esa edad porque porque
ya después no lo puede hacer uno ya no
puede hacer un equipo de 20 jugadores de
10 jugadores fueron a jugar casi y darle
a la raquetista el tenis de ayuda afuera
no
[Aplausos]
pero en un equipo como aquí estuvo lo de
jordan o cualquiera de sus buenos
equipos se aprende a jugar en equipo que
es lo más importante en la vida y esa ya
se hace ya después no yo tengo amigos
que ya vejetes ahora voy a correr y se
compra los panes naics tonterías no una
banda en la cabeza no
y tantas vueltas se refrendó una rodilla
porque porque no está entrenado de
jóvenes entonces nosotros tenemos que
precisamente entrenarnos para aprovechar
nuestro tiempo y para eso tenemos que
estudiar tenemos que leer
la gente no lee lecturas tonteras
ver cómo se usan estos aparatos la
televisión y el cine pueden ayudar
generalmente muy mal esas las novelas y
esos para embrutecer a la gente de veras
este el contacto con nuestro alrededor
tener amigos tener amigos viejos sobre
todo yo siempre tuve amigos viejos
porque porque los amigos viejos siempre
finalmente están sólo los viejos lo
invitan uno lo invitan tragos le dan
consejos y luego le dan gracias
es muy bueno verdad tener amigos viejos
no esté
y entonces uno empieza a agarrar ese
tipo de buenas costumbres
cuando usamos bien el tiempo no hay
tiempo para ser flojos no hay tiempo los
que sabemos el tiempo no son los últimos
que se van de la fiesta se saben medir
porque tienen que hacer el día siguiente
y no están en una todas las tardes en la
misma cantinela de 34 cervezas y
practicando las mismas tonterías y
queriendo arreglar el mundo cuando no
son capaces de ir a una manifestación
pero eso sí en la cantina arreglando
dick a kylie quien entonces este yo creo
que lo que se debe hacer precisamente
pues ver que somos privilegiados este
somos privilegiados los que estamos en
esta sala hay gente que no puede usar su
tiempo su tiempo se lo manipulan un
pobre hombre en el df que tiene que
hacer dos horas para ir a su trabajo y
dos horas para regresar qué tiempo le
queda
porque si pueden tener tiempo
entonces qué es lo que se debe hacer es
hacer planes de vida como ya dijeron
aquí anteriormente oigan dónde va a
estar entre 5 dentro de 10 años dentro
de 15 años hay gente que no piensa en
eso desde la prepa se debe de pensar que
se quiere hacer desde la prepa porque
porque para tomar un rumbo para conocer
cuáles son mis debilidades cuáles son
mis actitudes qué es lo que me gusta que
lo que no me gusta y entonces
precisamente formar una vida empezar en
el tiempo a estudiar quiénes han sido
buenos para eso yo creo que mucha gente
que está en el tamaño quieres hacer nace
de 22 años ya debería ser algo no
y ahora peor ahora agarran otras otras
carreras y otro y otro y otro y vuelvas
a trabajar
la mejor escuela del trabajo se los digo
de experiencia los que tenés que ahora
en todas las trabajos
si no tienes 34 títulos no te admiten
eso es una tontería a veces es bueno
estudiar pero bueno también trabajar
y aprender de la vida somos unos
privilegiados es igual a gente que no
puede controlar su tiempo y ese es el 50
por ciento de la humanidad este tenemos
que ver nuestro rumbo y ver que vamos
para allá y meterle ganas porque ahora
es tengo que hacer andar lo que me gusta
no es cierto lo que gusta
me los pongo de ejemplo
no hay que lauda
niki lauda acá hay un famoso corredor de
carros profesional como pocos una vez se
quemó toda la cara le dieron los santos
óleos y a los 30 días ya estaba
corriendo hay uno que convalecientes
nada chiquito esta noche a la hora de
cambiar
el volante y así es
dos años después de haber ganado el
grand prix paró el carro un día y dijo
yo ya no corro porque porque cuando esto
se vuelve una rutina uno se mata
entonces hay que buscar no aburrirse
hay que buscar la rutina es lo peor
tiene uno que buscarle a la vida ciertas
actitudes y la otra cosa también que es
muy difícil es la ociosidad la gente que
es ociosa está en la calle y sobre todo
hacer las cosas que podemos hacer a
nuestras diferentes edades poca gente
sabe envejecer porque no tiene hobbies
porque lo que estás haciendo ahora tú
estás haciendo un carrito de juguete
y tú qué haces ver la televisión y yo
digo entonces la gente tiene que
buscarle otras cosas en la vida y todo
va precisamente con la administración
del tiempo ustedes vean ya se me está
acabando el tiempo verdad tenemos que
estar viendo el relojito está muy groso
que de 100 frente
por qué
porque el tiempo el tiempo lo tenemos
medido lo tenemos medido este hay hay
que decir esta es mi último día qué
haría si fuera mi último día
y sobre todo también tener la audacia
verdad de no tomarse tan en serio
verdad ahí voy a hacer el ridículo
porque me gusta ver pajaritos
hay miles de gentes que se dedican en
eeuu viejos llenan su vida esté la
ociosidad hace que la gente se atrofia
muchos de los que son ya de edad
empiezan precisamente a no tener nada se
agarran el cohete de kabul y te lo son
23 y luego ya después de la torre no por
otro lado también esté la vida se acaban
y no sabemos cuándo nos va a tocar
entonces estos aparatos que tenemos ya
no tiene uno que ir a la universidad si
es o no listo aquí tiene todo pero no lo
sabemos usar nos ponemos a ver ahí las
puertas de fuller ni es que bien salió
el cancún oye ni lo conozco y están
aguantando no conoces luego un chiste
baboso
luego lo que odio más hay cumpleaños
perenganito hijos
le tengo que decir feliz cumpleaños
porque si no como hay 30 en ese en ese
en ese portal si no le dice 18 sentí
entonces feliz año punto les pongo yo
uno les pone en poemas y una bola de
cosas
dónde
esa de que orando inflando la hora que
me importa
yo por eso no sé mucho de esto lo agarro
para el negocio para cosas importantes
para teléfonos y por no saber más oye
que tiene brújula postal software que no
esté
una bola de cosas que aceptar y los ven
todos los días están tin tin tin tin
cuántas horas no se pierden esto yo les
aseguro y eso viendo cosas buenas porque
luego con la sociedad se empiezan a ver
cosas malas sobre todos los muchachos y
en la torre esto puede ser terrible
terrible entonces cuidado con estos
aparatitos cuidado precisamente con
todas esas distracciones de que traer a
la sociedad este yo ya yo fui fanático
del fútbol americano pero fanático jugué
siete años ahora nomás vio el último
cuarto para que para que veo más si te
dicen que pasó en el primer segundo y
tercero
el juego se acaba en los últimos minutos
no yo conozco gente que se pasa 33
juegos el domingo enfrente de la
televisión oye chiquito pues oye tu
tiempo está vivo por más emocionantes
que sean a subas no los puedes ver
después hombre no estás en el estadio
luego entonces yo lo que les pido es
aprovechen su tiempo porque nomás tienen
ciertos años ciertos minutos y esos no
vuelven muchas gracias